[Música]
comenzamos con nuestra revista de prensa
con Rosa Pérez mateu Rosa Buen día para
usted Buen día Ángela Y empezamos con el
tema de Ucrania y la deportación forzada
de menores a Rusia que vuelve a estar en
el centro del debate Desde que la Corte
Penal Internacional emitió por este
crimen de guerra una orden de detención
contra Vladimir Putin Cuál es la nueva
noticia al respecto exactamente Ángela
recordemos contra Vladimir Putin el
presidente Ruso y también contra el boba
belova que en esa de la responsable rusa
por los derechos de la infancia quien
presumió recordemos de haber adoptado
sin ir más lejos a una menor a una
adolescente de Mario Paul pues sabían lo
que ha sucedido Es que la viceprimera
ministra ucraniana irinader shock
advirtió digamos a los adultos rusos que
están adoptando a los menores ucranianos
que tarde o temprano van a tener que
pagar las consecuencias y les aconsejó
que continúen adoptando menores que en
sus palabras ha sido robados de Ucrania
bien por otro lado según una nota de la
agencia Efe informó ver el shock la
viceprimera ministra ucraniana que la
identidad de estas personas de estos
padres adoptivos o tutores alegales de
estos niños ucranianos deportados
forzosamente a Rusia no es la identidad
no es un gran secreto ni para las
fuerzas ucranianas ni para las fuerzas
internacionales además la primera
ministra la Vice primera ministra
Disculpen mencionó algunos de los
nombres de estas personas que han
adoptado a menores ucranianos para
mostrar no que su identidad está en
conocimiento de las autoridades
ucranianas y destacó por ejemplo Irina
ruzcaya katerina Y Dennis trípollets
Marina marchenko entre otros pero bien
nos preguntamos álgebra Cuántos son
exactamente los menores ucranianos que
han sido trasladados forzosamente a
Rusia y es que las cifras varían un poco
según la agencia reuters que al
Ministerio ucraniano de integración por
los territorios ocupados que lidera la
propia viceprimera ministra ucraniana
habrían sido
19.514 los menores ucranianos traslados
forzosamente a Rusia sin embargo según
un informe de Naciones Unidas con la
fecha del 15 de marzo que está
mencionado en un artículo de
ucrainapravda los menores trasladados
forzosamente a Rusia serían
16.221 desde el 24 de febrero de 2022
cuando empezó la invasión rusa y bien En
qué contextos digamos estos menores
ucranianos son capturados digamos por
las fuerzas rusas y trasladados a
territorio de la federación rusa pues
este informe de Naciones Unidas pone
algunos ejemplos Como por ejemplo cuando
los padres de estos niños son retenidos
en Checkpoints cuando los menores
pierden el contacto o pierden
definitivamente a sus padres se ha
debido a los combates o cuando estos
niños están en instituciones ucranianas
bajo tutela del estado ucraniano que cae
en bajo control ruso no en territorios
que caen bajo control de las fuerzas de
Moscú En todo caso según Ucrania serían
4.400 los niños que se encontraban en
estas instituciones huérfanos en su
mayoría que han sido trasladados a
territorio Ruso y bien para terminar
según las cifras oficiales ucranianas
desde que empezó la guerra 327 menores
han conseguido regresar a Ucrania desde
Rusia y explica la comisionada ucraniana
por los derechos de la infancia en una
entrevista al post que los menores que
han conseguido regresar no ha sido por
asenso con Rusia digamos no es que Rusia
y Ucrania estén colaborando en esto sino
ella dice que son operaciones
individuales apoyadas por el estado
ucraniano dice si los menores tienen
padres los padres tienen que ir a Rusia
a buscarlos el estado ucranianos ayuda a
la familia a conseguir documentos
necesarios planificar una ruta y
recuperar al menor si los rusos por
supuesto les dejan ir gravísimas
denuncias entre tanto la associate
entrevistó al presidente ucraniano
durante un viaje entrena a las zonas del
frente selensky dice que cualquier
Victoria rusa sería peligrosa
exactamente Y es que el mismo reconoce
que su gran reto en estos momentos en
este segundo año de la guerra es
mantener alta la moral tanto de la
población como del ejército y este es
una poco el objetivo de su visita en
tren a estas zonas cercanas al frente no
por eso mismo dice que es tan importante
la batalla de backmud que recordemos a
esta hora es la más larga de la guerra
del lensky asegura que perderla sería
más una derrota política y simbólica que
no una derrota táctica no precisamente
por eso dice que en estos momentos
cualquier Victoria rusa esa peligrosa
para la moral ucraniana también además
insiste en Que invita al presidente
chino a reunirse con él Algo que de
momento no ha suscitado ni una
confirmación ni tampoco un
desmentimiento por parte de las
autoridades chinas y por último señalas
yelenski que necesita el apoyo continuo
de sus aliados occidentales y que sabe
que un cambio político en Washington
sería muy perjudicial para que en esta
guerra dice Estados Unidos entiende que
si dejan de ayudarnos no ganaremos y las
periodistas señalan dijo en la
entrevista mientras bebía un sorbo de té
Sentado en una cama en la cabina
dormitorio estrecha y sin adornos de un
tren Estatal yo no sé qué vamos a hacer
vamos a tener que pedir más tiempo al
aire para usted para que podamos
comentar muchas más noticias que
lamentablemente hoy nos quedan en el
tintero Gracias Rosa y nos vemos mañana
a ti Ángela hasta mañana